décidément jacques mesrine le gangster
recherché par toutes les polices de
france depuis sa spectaculaire évasion
le 8 mai dernier du quartier de haute
sécurité de la prison de la santé à
paris
jacques mesrine aime faire parler de lui
il ya aujourd'hui de réaliser un hold-up
parfait sans tirer un seul coup de feu
il s'est emparé de 450 mille francs dans
une succursale de la société générale du
raincy dans le département de la seine
saint denis
il a reconnu en outre être l'auteur du
hold up du casino de deauville commis le
26 mai dernier
c'est à cette heure ce matin que mesrine
et un complice se sont présentés chez le
fondé de pouvoir de la société générale
du raincy après avoir que leur forme et
la femme et la fille de ce dernier
mesrine a laissé son complice au
domicile du fondé de pouvoir et s'est
rendu avec ce dernier à la société
générale où il s'est fait remettre les
fonds il a ensuite emprunté la voiture
de sa victime qu'il a laissée sur le
parking de la gare du nord à paris avant
de disparaître
jacques collet a rencontré pour nous la
victime de cette prise d'otages et de
soldes on m'a exposé ce qu'il voulait
c'était clair et simple notamment il est
injuste roland il m'apporte la faillite
il m'a mis le marché en main donc c'est
quoi son projet à son marché c'était la
bomba prise d'otage de ma famille et je
partais avec lui
beaucoup de travail
pour rançonner enfin pour relever en
fait l'échec il exprime et s'assure
qu'elle tend tout à fait quel moment
comme à son habitude donc de fait vous
êtes parti avec les ventes donc
demain d'istres sont partis d'ici et on
sait on est arrivé donc devant l' agence
9 heures de leur cinquième au palais de
là où on est rentrés puisque l'agent
s'était ouverte et c'est à ce moment là
donc
il m'a fait rentrer dans mon bureau en
fin d'après un scénario qu'elle est et
qui a été donc déterminé par lui et chez
apple donc nous battons et c'est là sous
la menace que nous sommes et est
descendu au coffre retirer des fonds
quelle somme je sais qu'on parle de 401
compile personnellement je ne veux pas
retourner à l'âge ans je pourrais vous
dire
le préjudice suis à cet égard quel a été
son comportement avec votre épouse votre
fils entré autres et dorian très correct
d'ailleurs il m'avait dit que si en fait
tout s'est passé normalement et
il sort est correct
des problèmes avoir de son côté si
vraiment les choses se tournait bien
s'ils n'y avaient pas d'anicroches
qu'est-ce que vous inspire précisément
le genre de comportement des truands
comme lille qui se permet de narguer la
police de venir chez à perdre
malheureusement
[Musique]